I do want to talk before we move on
about just a sort of addendum story to
the entire Ukraine impeachment Fiasco
Joe Biden scandal this is sort of an
ancillary story but it is part of the
continuing comedy of errors
that the white that the Trump White
House continues to be the Trump White
House accidentally set their talking
points on the Ukraine Fiasco directly to
House Democrats and Nancy Pelosi and
every time that I see a new headline
about the entire Ukraine fiasco I think
this one has to be wrong this one must
be from a satirical news website or
something but the headlines are real
there were talking points that the
Republicans put together the Trump White
House and with Republicans put together
to fight against House Democrats who of
course have since launched an
impeachment inquiry against Donald Trump
and they put those documents together
they put those talking points together
and then they sent them directly to
Democrats and this is the funniest thing
but after we do this I want to talk
about the content of the talking points
themselves so they send out the talking
points and it contains a defense of the
phone call between Trump and the
Ukrainian president why it was all great
how the real scandal is the leak about
the content of the phone call not the
content of the phone call itself and
then shortly thereafter the White House
realizing its mistake tries to recall
the message through their email system
which of course it was too late to do as
the ship had sailed and the talking
points had been published or were to be
published soon thereafter so more
incompetence at the Trump White House
but the content of the talking points is
actually the most important thing here
you can tell how weak the hand of
Republicans is by their talking points
for example their defense of the
allegation that there's a quid pro quo
between Donald Trump's military aid and
Ukraine smearing Biden their talking
point is that the aid package wasn't
specifically mentioned in the call and
as we've since found out the phone call
had as a precondition this desire to
talk about Joe Biden and the
investigation and the eventual smear
that they
it would come anyone who knows anything
about politics knows that this is not
how things work Trump doesn't personally
on the same call ask for an
investigation into Biden and say until
you do it I'm not giving you the money
this is not how politics works this is
not how quid pro quo works this is not
how ultimatums work and holding hostage
of military aid and of course we've
since found out that there was already a
discussion in advance and Rudy Giuliani
was involved and other people were
involved in setting the preconditions
for this phone call between Trump and
the Ukrainian president to even take
place these talking points that they
sent out as boneheaded as it is to send
it directly to Democrats are talking
points that would only even possibly
work on the most naive and uninformed
follower of politics you can tell how
weak their talking points are because
they mentioned the deep state in their
talking points they say as a suggested
talking point that this case just shows
another example of the deep state the
media and Democrats in Congress damaging
our national security they're suggesting
that Republicans defend Trump this is a
talking point they workshopped
presumably suggesting that we defend
that they defend Donald Trump by blaming
the deep state you know your talking
points are really weak when you have to
raise the deep state conspiracy to show
that everything Donald Trump did is OK
and then of course maybe just as
importantly in all of this is that we've
since learned the full scope of the
cover-up attempt that existed Donald
Trump ultimately releasing what was
initially called a transcript later
actually said well this is actually a
memo and really what it was is an
extraordinarily a small percentage piece
of the transcript and we know that when
you have a 30-minute phone call and you
put out a four-page double-spaced memo
you are cutting out a whole bunch of
stuff they made the calculation that
that was actually going to paint the
conversation in a better light than what
the full transcript would do which
should make us question what is in the
actual full
transcript here every single element of
this is a combination of complete and
utter incompetence like sending your
talking points the House Democrats and
the obviously short-sighted decisions
that are being made haphazardly this
will help us more than that other thing
happening not even realizing that they
are actually being further damaged even
by for example the partial transcript or
memorandum that they put out so look at
what has developed in the last 72 hours
and then think for a second what is
going to happen in the next 72 my
prediction for the next 72 hours is more
details about whistleblower number two
which involves the IRS I'm guessing by
Monday we will know a lot more about
that I predict another one of these
completely erratic unhinged tweet storms
over the weekend by Donald Trump my
prediction is that by Monday morning we
will be able to report to you that
Donald Trump has gotten even more
involved in everything
everything up to and including
obstruction and witness tampering
related to this whistleblower or
whistleblower number two and who knows
what else will have happened over the
weekend but certainly by Monday I
predict we will have a lot more to
report on here as well as the increased
support for the impeachment of Donald
Trump among the American public I
already saw one poll about that this
morning and my my prediction is by
Monday we will have even more so I'm
glad you're with us today we have so
much to discuss so much to talk about
make sure you're following me on Twitter
at des Pakman make sure you follow the
david pakman show on twitter at david
packard show and of course do not miss
my twitch livestreams at twitch.tv slash
david pakman if you have an Amazon Prime
subscription you can subscribe to me on
Twitch prime for free it costs you
nothing it counts as a paid subscription
for us at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
we will take a very quick break and be
back with so much more including more
impeachment discussion whistleblower
discussion 2020 discussion and so much
more today's program is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman if
you've not already heard about blinka
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet
or web browser and what they do is they
take nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a fifteen minute
audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudoscience
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n